baby muss man die goldenen sandalen
stehen jungen
jol herzlich willkommen zu diesem video
über eigenes erschlagen sie mal wieder
komplett und zwar hat er nämlich gestern
zum allerersten mal den award des jahres
verliehen und ich muss mir sagen mir
steht der kragen bis hier oben hin was
er sich da wieder geleistet hat
unfassbar und auch generell warum ich
jetzt direkt nach dem video in seinem
büro war und ihm erst mal meine meinung
sagen muss und ein bisschen hackmack
auch tatsächlich machen muss das
erfahren wir es gleich wir gehen jetzt
erst mal die materie reihen der albaner
ort quasi ist ein preis indem er quasi
den deutschesten in einer gewissen
kategorie küren sollte für sein stereo
typisch deutsches verhalten wir sehen ja
auch im hintergrund schon die weiteren
diesen warte bildschirm mussten sich
dann auch über die zuschauer anschauen
bis er sich dann endlich mal entschieden
hat vor die kamera zu treten jetzt
zuschauer dann fünf minuten 6 78 minuten
nach acht minuten ist dann dieses geile
intro ertönen
[Musik]
genial alle und das hat natürlich alle
sicherstellen
absolut gut hoch da gehen jetzt mal hier
durch das objekt der preis wird
verliehen für den grünen des jahres sehr
hoch werde ich hier einmal zu gewinnen
gibt hier die goldenen taler meine
freunde ihr seht extrem extrem
hochwertig gefertigt aus reepsholt
separate tatsächlich nicht überzogen
oder besprüht sondern eine echte
goldanteile und da steckt sogar ein
echter menschen fuß drin den wir
jemandem abgeschnitten haben
das ganze war toni wenn wir so aufgebaut
es gab verschiedene kategorien von alma
nied also einmal den albernsten tweet
des albums dem video den albernsten song
hier den eindruck da war zum beispiel
die tram ex giro und wer auch immer
nominiert wir gehen einfach mal ganz
flott durch da hat nämlich dann
tatsächlich remy seinen eigenen award
abkassiert echt sehr sehr stark dann
muss ein fuder der leberkäse weißwurst
als nominiert hat hier gewonnen ja vor
kartoffel noch respekt bier hast du
gemacht hast verdient bierwagen einmal
durch wir haben ja das absolute
improvisieren
[Musik]
was hier das transition gibt ihn hat
bruder muss los war dass ahlmann trend
was gewonnen hat ja die zuschauer
konnten live entscheiden und jetzt sehen
wir schon die kategorie in der auch ich
nominiert wurde und das war mal ein
video eine sache die definitiv sehr
polarisiert hat im zehnten jahr die auf
jeden fall extrem extrem steil gegangen
ist ja natürlich wie könnte es anders
sein die parodien meines katers thomas
von sex tape da war ich dann tatsächlich
als ich das zum ersten mal hört auf
etwas überrascht da ich war echt geehrt
muss ich an der stelle zu geben die
freude geht aber nicht lange warum das
so ist der evoque sich jetzt die einsam
sagte anja lässt den zuschauer also
einen kleinen einblick gewähren damit
sich auch eine meinung machen kann ja
haben wir zum beispiel dort endo ja der
sein millionen abonnenten button
bekommen hat herzlich willkommen an der
stelle auch mal hier
vielen dank für dieses gute stück das
ist letztens eingetrudelt 100.000 euro
hier mit meinem namen natürlich drauf
und haben das sogar mein gesicht darauf
gedruckt das vielleicht absolut genial
von den vielen dank auf jeden fall ein
allerdings möglich gemacht haben aber es
geht ja heute nicht um mich sondern um
dreh wie sorgt weiterhin hat er dann
auch auf das prototyp einmal video
reagiert ja dann ist es auch schon
soweit so viel zu dem nächsten und der
alliierten gehen wir noch weiter weg mal
jetzt hört das sextape parodie an meine
super mein video eine sache die auf
jeden fall glaube ich hat
hat er das gelöscht
man könnte auch suchen neben niveau ist
es da ist es war auch tatsächlich
nominiert für den mord an traumhafte
hier meine freunde dann schauen wir mal
ganz kurz hier ein sachen nächste
nominierten zu thomas extreme gute
auswahl dieses und kein anderes wenn
jetzt an der stelle schon mal bei 7 rein
prinzipiell sollte die bockwurst sogar
dieses gottverdammte dieses
gottverdammte ding durchschlagen aller
so deutsch ist das ja super wieder aus
weil hier das ein manometer zeigt dann
quasi immer den die alm einigkeit der
aktuellen sache ja und die amanit bei
mir natürlich gut man muss übrigens auch
sagen dass ich mittlerweile auf jeden
fall so sehe jetzt nie mehr aus ein
bisschen abgenommen bisschen habe ich
mich gehen lassen
ich weiß du hältst mich für babys blick
ist begeisterter unten haben wir genug
oder nicht
mach weiter jetzt ja stark gutleut ich
würde fast schon sagen und da ist es mir
dann auch geplant ist an der stelle
schon laser mir auch geplatzt er hat
einfach meine performance ja jemand
unterrichten im künstler nicht einfach
so während er live vor einem
millionenpublikum hervor
und da hat mir einfach die dem moment
genommen er war extrem bedeckt was
natürlich meine wut führt weswegen ich
da jetzt in seinem büro man muss jetzt
gleich mehr brauchen wir auch von thomas
gar nicht zu sehen
das habe ich getroffen weil hier der ist
richtig ahlmann stark mit seiner alm an
gestik
ja wir spielen mal direkt vor zur
preisverleihung sehr akzeptiert ist sehr
sehr sehr schöne und vor allen dingen
auch wirklich leben wertvoll ist das wie
gesagt kann ich wollte sagen
randale das ist ein 24 karat gerne
übrigens bei jedem gewinner hatte
nämlich immer so eine sandale in die
kamera gehabt und gesagt ja das ist eine
goldene sind alle stark und ich habe
mich am anfang eigentlich voll gefreut
und dann ist mir irgendwann aufgefallen
da habe ich eben die these aufgestellt
dass er einfach nur eine sandale hat und
die immer wieder in die kamera hält er
kann das eine bringschuld gar nicht
erfüllen dass er daneben sind alle gibt
und gerissene land darin schon meine
freunde so wir schauen mal ganz kurz
hier auf die ergebnisse gehen nach einem
ganz ganz kurzen schnitt
[Musik]
stark wir sehen hier auf jeden fall
gerade dass ich tatsächlich an der
stelle jetzt einfach mal ist das hat
mich einfach verletzt dieses gefühls
hoch und runter ich war erstmal den so
einer renommierten so einer anerkannten
in so einer wichtigen verleihung da war
ich nominiert war an der spitze hat
mitgefiebert hat tränen geweint habe
gelacht habe mich gefreut mich geärgert
habe mitgefiebert und dann weißt du es
sagen ich bin ein mof letzt hat momentan
einen gewinner
wir haben glaube ich ein gewinner
gewonnen als most einmal youtube video
hat dieses tolle herzlichen möglich
thomas du hast du doch die golden
sandale inklusive einer behandlung bei
mir höchst persönlich abholen extrem
schön thomas also die goldene die hole
ich mir jetzt auch gleich abgaben eine
bank in fünf minuten muss jetzt echt
lossprinten oder die kündigung die kann
er sich einfach gehalten und da gehen
wir der sache jetzt mal im nur ganz kurz
darauf noch angehen muss hierbei eine
mode und elf habe ich deswegen auch
direkt einmal ein abonnement gibt ja
einfach nur damit ich ihnen da schreiben
konnte der gerade hier seht ihr das
einfach nur damit in den schreiben kann
der gerade auch nur abonnenten
angestellt war ja was mich auch sagen
oder deshalb ist die aus dem stall lasst
mich in ruhe das reicht mir jetzt auf
jeden fall da gibt es richtig baby
wo ist gott eine sandale ich durst
gesagt jeder kriegt die ja ich würde
sogar gesagt ich kann mir heute abholen
verlust wirst ich habe hier ein
ausschnitt wurde gesagt hast ich kann
ihn mir morgen abholen und weil das
morgen die bleibt da stehen junge mann
nein doch junge aber die thomas die
brauche ich muss nichts ja aber du hast
ich dachte jeder kriegt zu einer ich
habe meine gebastelt aber warum bvb fan
[Applaus]
neulich habe ich die kohle ist so wie
sie mir zusteht und ich mache mich jetzt
mal ganz schnell vom acker bevor wir
schmeißen
[Musik]